la petite commune de murs et a concentré
ce dimanche tout ce qui se fait de mieux
en matière d'écologie stand de
réparation de vélos sacs fabriqués en
chambre éco construction mais
l'attraction la plus coût et a été de
loin le marché bio alimentaire il ya de
la diversité il ya du bio il ya du local
aussi surtout
donc ça fait plaisir ici les chalands
peuvent acheter leurs fruits et légumes
à des maraîchers qui cultive en bio
depuis des décennies mon père a été
précurseur en 82 et de on a fait des
envies ou à des motivations des gens qui
voulaient s'installer
et puis de la clientèle cas qui s'est
créé petit à petit aussi sur ce stand
jean christophe et sa femme vente des
fromages de chèvre issu d'un élevage
familial passer en bio en 1964 tout le
monde critique et beaucoup l'agriculture
biologique à l'époque et ils sont ici
tout le monde critique c'est peut-être
pas si mal que ça et donc ils ont essayé
puis ma foi ils ont fait toute leur
carrière on a repris on est en bio et
puis on est encore là et puis ça va bien
à bursey ses alentours ils ont été une
poignée à défendre les vertus du bio et
de l'ecologie dominique mansion fut l'un
de ceux là
écrivain spécialiste des trognes il est
à l'origine de la création de la maison
de la botanique 6 dans le petit village
on était vraiment en vue comme des
marginaux une certaine époque c'est
clair et maintenant avec tout ce qui se
passe on commençait délire mais là il ya
des choses essentielles
c'est le bio mais c'est aussi le
plessage la création de trognes afin de
travailler sur deux renouvelables de
leurs acides et dans le paysage des
choses qui ont du sens
une quête de sens et de plaisirs
gourmands qui a attiré 2500 visiteurs à
la 29e édition de cette fête bio
[Musique]